[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا ساعه جديده من هذه التغطيه
المستمره على قناه العربيه على مدار
الساعه
لليوم السابع على التوالي تستمر فاجعه
الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا عداد الضحايا في
ارتفاع مستمر اكثر من ثلاثين الف قتيل الى
الان الى ان تقديرات تشير الى ان حصيله
الضحايا ستكون اكثر بكثير من هذا العدد
خاصه مع تحول جهود الاغاثه الى عمليات
انتشال بعد ان خفت اصوات الانين تحت
الانقاض
عفوا نحن مستمرون معكم بهذه التغطيه على
مدار الساعه لهذا الحدث الجلل
[موسيقى]
اذا المشاهدين ان تتواصلوا في تركيا
عمليات الانقاذ وانتشال الناجين
وطبعا ناجين جدد من تحت انقاذ البنايات
المدمره ابرزهم من الاطفال حديثي الولاده
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنا لا مشاهدينا من غازي عنتاب زيدان
مراسل العربيه اهلا بك يزيدان معنا مره
اخرى زيدان عندما تحدثنا في الساعه قبل
الماضيه كنت تتحدث عن انه يعني عمليات
الانقاذ ورفع الانقاذ
طيب يبدو انها فقدنا زيدان زينجو مشاهدينا
سنحاول اعاده الاتصال به لمتابعه الحديث
ونقل الصوره تحديدا من غازي عنتاب اما
نتابع الان كل هذه القصص التي تدمي القلوب
طبعا من جراء هذا الزلزال فاكثر من سته
ايام منذ الزلزال المدمر مع مرور الوقت
يتلاشى امل العثور على احياء لكن اقارب
منهم تحت الانقاض يرفضون تصديق ذلك
قد ينتظر هؤلاء الى اجل غير مسمى فهذه
الوقفه وان طالت وسببت خضرا والما وهذه
الوجوه التي تترقب يبقى وجعها اخف وطاه من
هذه الوقفه حيث لا امى لا باق فقد وصل
النبا الذي لا يريد احد سماعه في هذه
الفوضى البحث جار عن صوت ضعيف يعلن عن
حياه لم يبقى امامها الكثير
يبقى صوت هذه الجرافات التي تحرك حجرا
ربما يكشف عن ابن او اخ او امن او اب
افضل من صوت تلك التي تعلن النهايه
رغما انحصار الامل في العثور على ناجين
جدد الا ان صوتا خافتا لرضيعا تركي لا
يتجاوز سبعه اشهر قضى منها سته ايام تحت
الركام هذا الصوت صوت تجند له عشرات
الايادي قبل ان تصفق لمعجزه رضيع اعلن او
اعلن ميلاده للمره الثانيه في النفس العام
وفي مشهد اخر يبعث الامل تمكنت فرق
الانقاذ في كهرمان مرعش التي تقع على بعد
70 كيلو متر عن مركز زلزال تمكنوا من
انقاذ زوجين موسنين بعد 138 ساعه قضوها
تحت الارض وفي موقع مجاور تمكنا ايضا
المنقذون من اجلاء شاب على قيد الحياه بعد
140 ساعه من الزلزال اما في مدينه هاتاي
فقد تكللت الجهود بالنجاح بانقاذ امراه
حامل وشقيقها عندنا
الله الله
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الحمد لله
الله يسلمك
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ومشاهدينا نذكركم ببعض الاخبار العاجله
التي وردتنا الان اذا المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان يقول للعربيه بانه لا يمكن اذا
احصاء عدد المفقودين جراء الزلزال لكن
العدد من المرجح ان يكون كبيرا جدا ايضا
المرصد قلل العربيه بان محدوديه
الامكانيات تسببت في فشل انقاذ احياء من
تحت الانقاض الان نذهب الى سرمده مباشره
معنا من هناك خديجه خطيب خديجه هي متطوعه
بالدفاع المدني السوري طبعا واحد ملائكه
الرحمه في هذا المصاب الجلل اهلا فيك
خديجه ويعطيكم الف عافيه بالفعل يعني جهود
جباره خصوصا انتم في سوريا حيث لا تتمكن
المساعدات او فرق الانقاذ المتطوعه التي
تدفقت على سوريا لا تستطيع ان تصلكم كل
التحيه يعني الحقيقه
الله يعطيكم الف عافيه خديجه يعني مش
عارفه من وين ابدا معك بصراحه
حدثيني عن الوضع الان في سرمدا كيف هو
طبعا جهودكم استمرت على مدى سبعه ايام وما
زالت مستمره ولكن هناك هل ما زال هناك
الكثير يعني
لفعله والكثير من الركام ما زال يعني
بحاجه الى رفع حتى تتمكنوا لي الوصول
للناس سواء كانوا على قيد الحياه ام عكس
ذلك
في البدايه شكرا كتير الك تحياتي لكم
جميعا والله
لشهدائنا ويغفر لهم
اما بالنسبه للوضع الراهن فنحن فعليا ما
ذكرتي على المدارس تبع ايام عم نشتغل على
الارض
والمناطق اللي انضررت بحارم بثنيا سلقين
وارمناز وجنديرس
من المدن والبلدات الضررت بشكل هائل
جهودنا مستمره ومتواصلين بالعمل ولكن مع
الاسف نحن فقدنا ارواح كان من الممكن
انقاذه
صرنا نعمل على البحث والانتشار من المتوقع
انه ينهي هاي
خلال اليومين المقبلين مع الاسف يعني كان
قبل
طيب طيب
سمعتيني خديجه
طيب
الصوت يتقطع بعض الشيء احنا حابين كثير
انه يعني نكمل معك هذا الحوار
انت ربما انت وامثالك من المتطوعين
بالدفاع المدني وفرق الانقاذ يعني ابرز او
افضل من يخبرنا عن هذه الماساه خديجه هل
مازال هناك امل لديكم بانه تستطيعوا ان
تصلوا لبعض الناجين تحت الانقاض رغم مرور
سبعه ايام راينا بعض المعجزات هل مازال
هناك مساحه لهذه المعجزات في سوريا
هلا في صراحه يعني الوضع
يعني معدوم نحن اساسا عم نعمل بامكانيات
كتير قليله ومعدات قليله الوضع معدوم وصفه
موضوع انه تكون او تنوجد روح لسه فيها نفس
يعني او روح على قيد الحياه صفه موضوع شبه
مستحيل خلينا نقول انه الاشخاص اللي
تضرروا ما زالوا تحت الانقاذ فهمي كانوا
مصابين في حالات النزف فهي كتير خطيره على
صحه الانسان بالاضافه الى درجات الحراره
اللي كتير بارده وتلامس صفر فهذا بيعمل
اضطراب بالشوارد واضطراب بالوظائف الحيوي
وايضا متلازمه الهرس ما بدنا ننسى انه هاي
بنايات كامله وقعت على اهلنا المدنيين
فسببت متلازمه هاريس لاهلنا الموجودين ضمن
هذه
العوامل تحت الانقاض يقدروا يتواصلوا على
المعيشه في ظل سبع ايام بغض النظر ايضا عن
الاكل والشرب والضوء والحراره يعني الوضع
فعليا كتير صعب فرص الحياه شبه مستحيله
فنحن صرنا نعمل على انتشار
للجثث مع الاسف
طيب خديجه يعني انت لاحظنا بانه يعني هناك
اطفال
برضع
استطاعوا ان يصمدوا تحت هذا تحت الركام
وخرجوا على قيد الحياه بينما يعني ابائهم
لم يحالفهم هذا الحظ من واقع خبرتك وما
رايتيه ما الذي يجعل يعني او يعني من
الصعب تخيل بانه طفل رضيع بهذا العمر
يستطيع ان يصمد هل هو موضوع متعلق بحجم
الجسم ام انه هذه فقط عنايه رب العالمين
اكيد هي عنايه من رب العالمين بس في موضوع
نحن لازم نذكره وهو كتير ضروري نحن في عنا
شي عم بنواجه وعم بنشوفه بام العين وفي
بعضهم موثق بفيديوهات
ومع الاسف انا شو يعني شفته بام عيني لما
صارت الهز الام
ركزت على اطفال الصغار حضنتهن فحمتهم
بجسدهم وايضا للاب حتى في اطفال بعمر
الصغير كتير ما بيتجاوز عمرهم العشر سنين
مع انه طالعناهم جثمان احد من من
طفلتين كان جوزمان والتاني كانت على قيد
الحياه لانه اللي كانت كبيره كانت حميده
بجسدها وبنفسها في موضوع فداء كبير صار
بهاي الكارثه
يعني فعلا هو يعني هذا تجسيد
لقوه
واهميه يعني الانسانيه والتضحيه في مثل
هذه الظروف للاسف يعني كل عائله مكلومه
بفقدان حتى لو شخص واحد منها فما بالك اذا
من استطاع النجاح هو ربما اصغر من في هذه
العائله خبرينا اكثر عما رايتيه يعني كيف
كانت عمليات الانتشال هل الاشخاص الذين
كانوا في الطوابق العليا كان لهم فرص
للنجاه اكبر من الاشخاص الذين سقطت كل
يعني
ادوار البنايه فوق راسهم مثلا
فعليا هو اللي كان بالطوابق العليا كان في
عنده فرص معيش اكثر لانه نحن بالياتنا
الضعيفه كنا قادرين على انه يعني نشتغل
بما نواجه يعني
نحضر نفق لحتى نقدر نوصل لتحت للداخل بس
في كثير مواقف كانت فعليا مؤثره وكانت
فعليا اخذت مننا من قلبنا ومنروحنا
وخلتنا نوقف يعني عاجزين عن الكلام فيها
في اطفال بعمر ال14 15 سنه تم انقاذهم
كانوا موجودين بالطابق الرائع ولكن فعليا
الطابق الرابع والخامس صاير بما بما يعني
بطول مترين او بطول ثلاث امتار الوضع
فعليا كان كثير كثير صعب وكان كثير ماساوي
في اشخاص نحن كنا بالطوابق الارضيه فبعد
ما طالع
وبعد ما طالع احد ابناء فرجع حتى يطالع
ابنائه الباقين فما قدر والبنايه كانت
مهدمه بقى هو بناته موجودين احنا كنا
للساعات الاولى قادرين انه نتواصل معه بما
يقارب يعني عشر ساعات او 12 ساعه قادرين
انه نتواصل معه وسامعين صوته عم نحاول
نوصل له ولكن العائق كان انه كان في خمس
طوابق فوق ومعدات كانت قليله فما كنا
قادرين نوصل لهم مع الاسف فارق الحياه
بدون ما نقدر نوصل له وهل استطعت وانقاذ
بناته ايضا للاسف واجهوا نفس المصير
الحياه
طيب خديجه يعني جميعنا نعرف ما تعاني منه
سوريا والمناطق السوريه في الشمال الغربي
والغرب من سوريا التي ضربها زلزال الوضع
السيء جدا التي تعانيه من نقص في كل شيء
حطينا اكثر عن هذا الموضوع هل بدات الان
على الاقل بعد سبعه ايام ان تصلكم اي نوع
من انواع المساعدات معدات متطوعين مساعدات
للذين شردوا لمن تم انقاذهم ولكن الان
يعني يفترشون الارض ويلتحفون السماء
بالبدايه بالساعات الاولى او بالايام
الاولى تحديدا وصلنا كانت الاعمال جهود
مدنيه ومنظمات محليه للاشخاص الذين
تطوع المصري كان مؤلفه ما يقارب 15 شخص
فكانوا معنا على الارض وساندوننا
بالنسبه
للقوافل التي تجهت من الامم المتحده فهي
كانت مجدوله وكانت يعني غير مخصصه
لتارست الزلزال فما كان انه في الا انه
العمل مجدول وتم استئنافه فيما بعد
الفارسي
بالايام بالايام هي الاخيره قبل يومين
الاخيرين فدخلوا قوافل المساعده من
المجتمع الدولي فكل الشكر لهم وكل الشكر
لكل المساعدات اللي دخلت يا خديجه
كانت عباره عن مواد غذائي وتدفئه لاهلنا
المتضررين من حادثه الزلزال
طيب خبرينا عن يعني من استطعتم انتشالهم
وانقاذهم من تحت الانقاض شو كانت اصاباتهم
حالتهم هل تفاوتت
حاله يرثى لها من ناحيه صحيه من ناحيه
اصاباتهم وخصوصا انه للاسف الشديد يعني
نحن نفرح وقلبنا يعني يفرح بشكل كبير
عندما نسمع جميعنا واكيد انتم كمان عندما
تستطيعوا انقاذ احدهم ولكن للاسف بعض منهم
يعني يتوفوا بعد ذلك من جراء هذه الاصابات
مع الاسف اغرب المرضى اللي عم او اغلب
الجرحى اللي عم يتم انقاذهم عم يكونوا
بحاله اضطراب شوارد وانخفاض شديد في درجات
الحراره بسبب الوضع عم يكون تحت الانقراض
وطبعا وكلياتهم نفس السويه ولكن كلياتهم
فعليا
للمشافه الموجوده فالضغط على المشافع عم
بيكون فيها نحن عم نحاول دائما انه نقوم
بالاسعافات الاولانيه انه نحن كوادر مؤهله
للعمل على الانقاذ والاسعافات الاوليه
فدائما اي شخص او اي طفل او اي امراه عن
نوصل الها
دائما على تسريب على فتح وريد وتسريب
سوائل وشوارد لها عم يتم
فحص الوظائف الحيوي ونحن على تواصل معها
او مع اي شخص نحن موجودين معه
تواصل مباشر نقدر انه نوصل لهم نفحص
علاماتهم الحيويه ونقدر ندبر بما نستطيع
يعني عم بتكون المساحه صغيره ولكن نحن عم
نقدر انه نقدم هاي المساعده
بعض الاشخاص مع الاسف
ولكن عم يكون باضطراب كتير شديد بالوظائف
الحيوي ما عم نوصل للمشفى الي عم يكونوا
مع الاسف
نعم حياه
مختصه بالانقاذ بهيك حالات نعم شكرا جزيلا
الك يا خديجه
ويعطيكم الف عافيه
ونشد على اياديكم يعني وكان الله في عونكم
وعون طبعا كل المتضررين من جراء هذا
الزلزال من سرمدا مشاهدينا خديجه خطيب
متطوعه بالدفاع المدني السوري
نايف انت ترى اكثر اكثر مني انا لا استطيع
مشاهده
نعم الان نايف الان نايف كما تشاهد الان
نايف كما تشاهد يتم نعم الان كما تشاهد
نايف
نعم نايف نعم
نعم نايف لكن طلبوا منا ان نصمت يعني لكن
عائشه عائشه الان نايف الحمد لله عائشه
خرجت من فم الموت
عائشه الان تخرج بعد ولاده عسيره وولاده
قيصريه نايف عيش تخرج من رحم الركام نايف
لا ادري ان كنت تسمعني انقطع الاتصال لا
ادري ان كنت تسمعني
اكدوا يعني
لا ادري كيف كنت تسمعني انقطع الاتصال ان
كنتم
الان يعني يحاولون تثبيت
الان يثبتون الان يثبتون الان الان نايف
الان نايف بسرعه بسرعه
الان نايف نايف ان كنت تسمعني ان كنت
تسمعني ان كنت تسمعني
كنت تسمعني ان كنت تسمعني الان نايف على
اكتف نعم على اكتف نعم عائشه على اكتف
المسافين باتجاه الاسعاف عائشه عائشه يا
نايف عائشه تخرج من رحم الركام عائشه تعود
للحياه عائشه تخرج من فم الموت نايف عائشه
بعد ولاده قيصريه بعد ولاده عسيره عائشه
الان الى الاسعاف الان تصل الاسعاف نايف
وتحمل الان بالاسعاف تحمل بالاسعاف الان
لحظه فرح
مع تزايد اعداد ضحايا الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا الا ان ثمه قصصا بطوليه لعالقين
بين الركام صمود اصحابها احدث حاله من
الدهشه لدى فرق الانقاذ حتى انه بات هناك
تمت رابط انساني بين المنقذين والمنقذين
[موسيقى]
هنا يمكنك ان تلمس معجزات تنطق بها الارض
قالها فريق انقاذ الماني يعمل في تركيا
رابط انساني عجيب بين عمال الانقاذ وضحايا
الزلزال
دون ساعات طويله يتحدثون الى المنكوبين
يحاولون التخفيف من الامهم حينا واحيانا
كثيره يلقون اليهم باي وسيله ممكنه قد
تعيد اليهم الامل من جديد
زينب كرمان السيده التي خرجت على قيد
الحياه بعد اربع ساعات تحدت خلالها البرده
وانعدام اسباب الحياه بعد يوم من انقاذها
تلقت فرق الانقاذ خبر وفاتها
التزموا الصمت دعوه يكررها المنقذون
للمتجمهرين حول حطام المباني لعلهم يدركون
استغاثه ناج هنا او هناك
وخلال احدى لحظات الصمت تلك تحديدا في
قهرمان مرعش انتبه عمال الانقاذ لمعجزه
جديده
عائشه الطفله ذات السبعه اعوام خاضت صراعا
طويلا لمده سته ايام وسط امل وخوف اطبق
على المكان لساعات طويله لتولد من جديد
التشبث بالحياه رساله يواصل كتابه سطورها
من هم تحت الانقاض فهذا الرضيع الذي يبلغ
من العمر شهرين خرج حيا وسط ذهول كل من
يتابع المشهد
سيد الحديدي العربيه
معنى لا مشاهدينا من انطاكيا التركيه
الصحفي في شبكه نهر ميديا عهد الصليبي
اهلا بك عهد معنا عهد يعني عمليات الانقاذ
وانتشال الضحايا من تحت الركام مستمره
حدثنا عن الصوره لديك الان خصوصا ونحن
الان بعد سبعه ايام او دخلنا اليوم السابع
بعد هذا الزلزال هل ما زال هناك اصوات
خافته تنطلق من تحت هذه الانقاض
نعم صباح الخير لكم والاستاذ المشاهدين
نحن اليوم نبدا في اليوم السابع من حدوث
الزلزال المدمر في الجنوب التركي والشمال
السوري مدينه انطاكيا كانت صاحبه النصيب
الاكبر في هذا الزلزال تدم تدمرت بشكل
كامل لم يتبقى في المدينه سوى هذه الابنيه
التي ايضا هي مصدعه ومشققه جميعها نحن
الان نتواجد في هذه المنطقه التي تحتوي
مركزا للايواء يتبع لفريق ملهم التطوعي في
نادي حماه الاجتماعي هذه المنطقه الاكثر
امانا داخل مدينه انطاكيا اذا تحدثنا عن
الناجين حقيقه من يعني
يتصور كميه الركام التي تكون فوق الضحايا
يعتقد ان المنطقه لن يخرج منها اي حي على
الاطلاق لكن سبحان الله يعني قدره الله
على تحمل هؤلاء الناس تحت الركام هذه
المده الطويله يعني يدفع الامل لدى
الكثيرين ممن فقدوا ذويهم في هذه الحادثه
لي
فريق يعني يعني مختلط من السوريين واخرين
من فرق الانقاذ المشتركه التركيه وغير
تركيا من انقاذ خمسه اشخاص سوريين من وسط
الركام على يعني يعني مساحه يعني ربما
تقدر
بعشرين او ثلاثين بناء جميعها مدمره
بالكامل استطاعوا اخراج هؤلاء الاحكام
الخمسه من وسط هذه المدن التي هي جميعها
اصبحت كومه ترابيه استطاعوا اخراج هؤلاء
الخمسه اشخاص يعني حتى الساعه العاشره
ليلا لم يتم اخراجهم بشكل كامل فتبقت يعني
بعض اجسادهم تحت الركام لكن قاموا يعني
الفرق الموجوده باسعافهم ببعض الامور
الاسعافيه الطارئه اعتقدهم تم يعني
اخراجهم بشكل تام يعني خلال ساعات القليله
الماضيه كان هناك توقع ان في هذه المنطقه
اشخاص احياء اخرين سته ايام لم تكن هينه
كذلك الامر استطاع يعني استطاع الفرق
الانقاذ من اخراج
عائله متوفاه جميعها باستثناء طفل عمره 21
يوم جميعهم سوريين طبعا باستثناء طفل عمره
21 يوما مضى سته ايام منها داخل الركام
ووسط الركام وهو بصحه يعني تعتبر جيده
يعني الاوضاع هنا في هذه المنطقه ماساويه
حقيقه دخلت فرق الانقاذ بشكل كثير لكن على
ما يبدو ان انها لن تستطيع بانهاء هذه
الماساه في فتره وجيزه الماساه كبيره جدا
مدينه مدمره بالكامل
تحتاج مدينه انطاكيا كانت تحتضن الكثير من
السوريين يعني باعداد كبيره يا عهد كانت
تسكن في تلك المناطق ايضا التي تضررت داخل
تركيا في الزلزال تحديدا انطاكيا
نعم نعم سيدتي هي يعني المناطق التي تضررت
والمنازل تحديدا التي تضررت هي يعني
غالبيه المنازل السوريين منطقه انطاكيا ت
ضم سوريين يعني قدره ما بين 2300 الف جميع
المناطق الحدوديه ما بين سوريا وتركيا هي
تحتوي العدد الاكبر من النازحين في اورفا
وغازي عنتاب وانطاكيا
التي تعدت بشكل مباشر كان النصيب السوريين
من هذا الزلزال يعني ليس بالقليل ليله امس
ايضا كنا اليوم اعمل كصحفي لكنني عندما قد
المنطقه تركت عمل الصحافه يعني الى جانب
الطريق وبدات بعمليات الانقاذ وشكلنا فرق
سوريه لمتابعه يعني جمعنا ذاته او قائمه
اسماء للمفقودين مع عناوينهم واخر معلومه
وردت عنهم واستطعنا من الوصول الى الكثير
منهم وبفضل الله استطعنا ايضا من اخراج
بعضهم احياء
مرور فتره طويله من وجودهم يا عهد الاشخاص
الذين تمكنتم بحمد الله يعني ان
تخرجوهم من تحت الانقاذ اوضاعهم سواء كانت
الصحيه او حتى من كان وضعه الصحي يعني جيد
اين هو الان ما هي مراكز اهل يعني يتجمعون
في مراكز ايواء هل لديهم ما يكفيهم من
مساعدات وما الى ذلك
نعم الحاله الصحيه لكل الذين يعني استطعنا
من اخراجهم من وسط الركام متوفره وتحقيقه
اول حاله كانت حاله مساويه حقيقه يعني لا
يوجد الا التنفس واستطعنا ايضا استخراج
السيده من وسط الركام وتم نقلها الى مشفى
انطاكيا ومن ثم لم تردني معلومه الى اي
نقلت خاصه انني لم اعرف هذه العائله ولم
اعرف الا انها سوريه وكان هناك مناشدات
يعني مساعدتها من داخل الركام بعد يعني
النقلها الى مشفى انطاكيا انقطعت
الاتصالات معهم واتمنى ان تكون بصحه جيده
حاله اخرى يعني الطفل الذي اخرج
ظهر امس حالته تعتبر جيده على العلم ان
يعني عائلته جميعها قتلت في هذا الزلزال
جميعهم في نفس المكان في بناء مؤلف من سته
طوابق يعني الذين خمسه
اشخاص جميعهم بصحه جيده هناك حاله ايضا
يعني استطعت من توثيقها بعدست هذه لشاب
سوري ايضا اخرجناه من
من تحت الارض كان فوقه يعني عدد كبير من
الاسقف والركام وبعد ان خرج يعني سبحان
الله كان متبسما اول مشهد كان له متبسملا
عندما رانا واخرجناه وهو بصحه جيده كان
حاملا بيده هاتفه اللقال يعني وتكلم بجمله
قال هات طفل من الشحن يعني وكانه هو يعني
يعتذر منه انه طفل موبايل وانه احنا ما
قدرنا نوصل له اخرجنا حقيقه ذره من الغبار
لم يصب ذره من الغبار علما ان فرق الانقاذ
قالوا لنا لا يوجد احد في هذا المنزل لكن
اصرارنا على ان هناك احد في هذا المنزل
يعني بالنسبه القليله يعني التي كانت
تدفعنا الى هذا الامر وتجمعنا كسوريين
ويعني تعرضنا مع بعض استطعنا اخراج هذا
الشخص لكن بقيه عائلته لم يخرج منها الا
طفل واحد والسيده وطفله اخرى قتلوا حقيقه
ليله امس كذلك الامر هناك حاله اخرى
لشخص من ريف ادلب يعني فقد عائلته بشكل
تام استطعنا من استقبال الفرق انقاذ من
جنسيات مختلفه لمعرفه مصير الطفلات
الثلاثه مواليدتهم حقيقه الامر محزن جدا
الوالد اصيب بالجنون حاولنا قدر المستطاعا
يعني نخفف من روعته لكن المصاب جلل
استطعنا يعني استجلاب بعض الفرق الاجنبيه
التي يعني لديها كلاب مخصصه لهذا الامر
وكذلك اجهزه لفحص النبض
النبض والتنفس وكذلك الامر كاميرات لمعرفه
اذا كان هناك جثث في هذا المكان لكن للاسف
بعد البحث لمده ما يقارب ست او سبع ساعات
يعني تاكدنا منهم جميعهم توفوا والان
اعتقد خلال ساعات القادمه سيتم العمل على
اخراج جثثهم من داخل هذا الركام يعني
الماسي كثيره حقيقه هنا الاولويه هي لمن
وردت عنه انه سمع صوته او اعطى ايه اشاره
اذا اذا
تحدثنا السهوله ان تسمع صوت من تحت ركام
بنايه من عشر طوابق يعني لاي ناجين ربما
هم يصرخون اسفل هذه اسفل هذا الركام هذه
الكومه الهائله لكن من هم في الخارج لا
يسمعون على كل حال طبعا الماسي كثيره
وستكثر حتى عندما تروى هذه القصص في
الايام القادمه يعطيكم الف عافيه يعني كل
من شارك في جهود الانقاذ
يعني غوث هؤلاء وفي نفس الوقت في نفس
الوقت يعني كان الله في عونكم على ما
ترونه بام العين انتم في هذه المواقع شكرا
جزيلا لك صحفي في شبكه نهر ميديا عهد
الصليبي
رغم الارهاق وقساوه الظروف الجويه يعكف
جيش من المتطوعين على توفير الطعام والدفء
للمتضررين من الزلزال ولعناصر الانقاذ
والاغاثه على حد سواء
الى هذه الصور في وسط الطريق والتي هي
تعكس الواقع من
المتطوعين الذين يقومون في هذه الاثناء
وعلى مدار الايام بتحضير الشاي وايضا
القهوه للعاملين ولكل الذين يريدون او
يمرون في المدينه وكما ان نرى ايضا هنالك
مجموعه الان من الشبان الذين حضروا من عده
مناطق الى هذه المنطقه وهم الان مع ساعات
الفجر الاولى
منهم من يستريح ومنهم من كان في الورشه
ينتظر عينه او برهه من الوقت ثم بعد ذلك
ينتقل وايضا على جانب الطريق هذه الصور
لهذه الاواني التي يطبخ فيها كما نشاهد
الان وهي للشوربه الساخنه من هذه الجهه مع
البطاطا وايضا للشوربه العدس والتي تقدم
منذ عشره منذ سته سبعه ايام الى كل من
يدخل المدينه من اهلها او قبيلا العاملين
فيها او من الذين ياتون من المناطق الاخرى
نشاهد ايضا الاستراحه للعمال الذين ياخذون
الان قسطا من الراحه بعد 24 ساعه وهذه
الخيام التي نراها وهذا المطبخ هو عباره
عن تقديم الطعام والدعم واللوجستي لكل
الفرق ولكل الذين يمرون على الطريق حتى ان
الخبز والفاكهه وكل الاحتياجات من بطاطا
بالاضافه الى مياه هذا المطبخ هو صوره
مصغره عن مئات المطابخ الموزعه والمنتشره
على طول المدينه والتي ايضا قامت بها
الجمعيات الاهليه وقامت بها الجمعيات
المدنيه وقامت ايضا بها الحكومه واذهب معك
الى هذه الصوره
المعبره جدا عن الالم لانتظار الذين تحت
الركاب لهذا العامل وايضا لاقاربه الذين
هم تحت الركب هو يوقد
بنا ناري ماء يمكن ان يساعده ويخفف عنه
هذا البرد بالاضافه الى انه يبيت في
العراق
تعد المعابر الحدوديه بين تركيا وسوريا
طوق النجاه الاخير للناجين من هول الزلزال
المدمر في شمال غرب سوريا نتعرف معا على
ابرز هذه المعابر الحدوديه
[موسيقى]
ان جونا هنا في شمال غرب سوريا المنكوبه
حياتهم مرهونه بحبل نجاه اخير يتمثل بفتح
المعابر الحدوديه مع تركيا كي تعود الحياه
شبه طبيعيه بعد زلزال قضى على البشر
والحجر
لكن ما هي اهم المعابر الحدوديه بين سوريا
وتركيا وايها يعمل ليكون شريان حياه لاكثر
من اربعه ملايين شخص في شمال سوريا
معبر باب الهوى هو حاليا المعبر الرسمي
الوحيد في شمال ادلب لعبور المساعدات
الانسانيه الى سوريا بموجب قرار مجلس
الامن الدولي تسيطر عليه المعارضه السوريه
معبر باب السلامه في منطقه اعزاز شمال حلب
تسيطر عليه فصائل المعارضه السوريه معبر
جرابلس في ريف حلب تسيطر عليه فصائل
المعارضه السوريه ايضا
دوليا المنظمات الامميه طالبت النظام
السوري بتسهيل مرور المساعدات الى مناطق
المعارضه من دون قيد او شرط اما مجلس
الامن فسيعقد الاسبوع المقبل جلسه لمناقشه
امكانيه السماح للامم المتحده بارسال
مساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا عبر اكثر من
معبر حدودي
بدوره النظام السوري اعلن موافقته على
ايصال مساعدات للمناطق المتضرره الخارجه
عن سيطرته
واستردد تركي بعد ان قالت انقره انها تدرس
قرارها محاسن حضاره العربيه
طلب مبعوث الاتحاد الاوروبي الى سوريا
دانستونيسكو النظام السوري بعدم تاسيس ملف
المساعدات الانسانيه في الوقت ذاته ايضا
رفض المبعوث اتهام الاتحاد الاوروبي بعدم
تقديم ما يكفي من المساعدات للسوريين في
اعقاب الزلزال المدمره الذي ضرب مناطق في
سوريا وتركيا الاسبوع الماضي مضيفا ليقدم
المساعدات الى سوريا منذ اكثر من عشر
سنوات بل ويقدموا المزيد خلال ازمه
الزلزال وفق تعبيره
معنا الان مشاهدينا من دمشق الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي غسان يوسف اهلا بك غسان
معنا استاذ غسان يعني بدايه نتحدث بما انه
كنا نتحدث عن المعابر ضروره فتح هذه
المعابر على الحدود السوريه التركيه لدخول
هذه المساعدات وكل هذه التصريحات التي
تتحدث عن انه الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يعني
يرسل هذه المساعدات هل تصل اي منها هل
ايضا يعني هناك خطه
لتامين هؤلاء الذين
عانوا الامرين تحت الانقاض والان يعانون
اكثر ايضا بعد انقاذهم
تحياتي لك وللساده المشاهدين طبعا هو
الوضع انساني بكل معنى الكلمه وطبعا يعني
هم اهلنا واحبتنا ومسواء كانوا في المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها الدوله او في المناطق
الخارجه عن سيطره الدوله وهذا يعني كان
توجه الدوله منذ اليوم الاول يعني عندما
وقع الزلزال كان هناك اجتماع طارئ للرئيس
الاسد ووجه بان تصل مساعدات الى كل مكان
وان تصل فرق الانقاذ يعني وكل وعمل كل ما
يمكن عمله وقال الوقت الان في العمل
النظام لم يرسل اي فرق انقاذ الى المناطق
التي ليست تحت سيطرته والتي هي المناطق
المنكوبه اكثر نتحدث عن حلب ريف حلب عن
ادلب هل فتح هل تم فتح المعابر من الجانب
السوري الى الجانب السوري الاخر لدخول كل
هذه المساعدات والمعدات لانتشال
الناس من تحت الركاب
طبعا يعني وكان هناك اتصالات مع الجانب
التركي والجانب الروسي
لادخال الفرق انقاذ ولكن لم يكن هناك
استجابه لاخر ولم يكن هناك من تتحدثين معه
ولذلك طلب الدوله السوريه منظمات الامم
المتحده التي كانت
وقالت باننا يمكن ان نتعامل مثلا ندخل
الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري ولكن الطرف
الثاني رفض قالوا بان يعني طالب الدوله
بان يكون الصليب الاحمر الدولي بسيطا
وجهزت قوافل الاغاثه وهي منذ اول امس يعني
14 قافله تقف عند معبره في سراقب ولا تلقى
يعني جوابا من الطرف الاخر
تتحدث هنا استاذ غسان على الجانب السوري
يعني ربما يعني الوضع على الحدود التركيه
مختلف ولكن طيب الخط الفاصل ما بين مناط
المعارضه ومناطق النظام
يعني كالعاده تكون تركيه مثلا هي وروسيا
من تنسقا هذه الامور وتدخلان المساعدات
الانسانيه من المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
الدوله الى داخل ادلب عندما وقع الزلزال
انشغلت تركيا بنفسها واعلن الكثير من
المسؤولين وحتى من الاعلاميين ان تركيا
بنفسها والاتحاد الاوروبي كان غائبا
والمنظمات الدوليه كانت رائده وانت تعرفين
بان الجيش العربي السوري او اي حتى فرق
الانقاذ لا تستطيع الدخول الى تلك المناطق
بدون ان يكون هناك طرف ضامن وان يكون هناك
تنسيق مع رؤساء المجموعات المسلحه يعني هل
تتكلمين الدوله السوريه مع محمد الجولاني
مثلا او مع ابو عمشه او مع اي قائد من
مجموعات مسلحه لا يوجد طرف ثالث يعني تلك
الفتره يعني يجب ان يكون هناك اما منظمات
الامم المتحده تم تركيه اما يعني من
يستطيع ان يسير يعني حتى تصوري عندما
حاولت يعني من شمال جاءت قافله تحمل النصر
من شمال سوريا ووصلت الى معبر ابو زلوم
عند في شمال غرب سوريا رفض ما يسمى رئيس
حكومه الانقاذ عبد الرحمن مصطفى الاستلام
هذه الشحنات بالقول انه لم تاتي الاوامر
من تركيا وعندما ادخلت تركيا مساعدات
انسانيه قبل يومين يعني وهي ليست خاصه
بالزلازل وهنا يعني نعود لما ورد في تقرير
بان اوروبا لم تتخلى اوروبا لم ترسل شيء
يعني ولم يعني هو قال من عشر سنوات يرسلون
المساعدات انا اقول لك بانهم في هذا
الزلزال لم يرسلوا شيء ولم يدخلوا شيء
ويعرفون بان المناطق يعني مثلا التي الطرق
التي تصل الى سوريا من جهه التربيه مدمره
ولكنها لم يتكلموا مع الدوله السوريه
لادخال المساعدات رغم ان الحكومه السوريه
قالت بانها جاهزه الادخال المساعده من اي
بعمره ومن اي مكان وان الهدف هو الانسان
السوري ولكن كان هناك تقصير من الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومن منظمات الامم المتحده اعود
لاقول لك عندما دخلت مساعدات الدوريه سما
بشاحنات منذ يومين دخلت الى داخل مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا نصبت المجموعات مسلحه
الحواجز وحولت ان تستولي على هذه
المساعدات كلهم يريد ان ياخذ حصته وحتى
حدث اشتباكات بين هذه المجموعات فانا اقول
لك غياب الطرف في تلك المناطق هو الذي ادى
الى تاخير المساعدات وغياب منظمات الامم
المتحده وغياب يعني كل من هو يستطيع ان
يدخل هذه المساعدات انا اقول لك بشكل عام
يعني هناك تخلي كامل من الامم المتحده من
الولايات المتحده من الاتحاد الاوروبي من
كل المنظمات المتحده حتى من الصليب الاحمر
حتى منظمه الصحه العالميه متى اتى مدير
عام منظمه الصحه العالميه امس حتى كان في
حلب ولذلك يعني هون تخلوا عن شمال غرب
سوريا وتخلف ايضا عن سوريا لاحظ التمييز
ما بين يعني مثلا تركيا وسوريا لاحظي ان
يعني مثلا حتى الولايات المتحده يعني كانت
تفرض علينا الحصار وعندما قالوا رفعنا
الحصار يعني هذا اعتراض منهم بانهم
ولاحظ التمييز يعني عندما يقولون لك
النظام والنظام والنظام غير ذلك طيب الناس
الذين اخذوا في الزلزله ليسوا بشر اليسوا
سوريين مثل غيرهم مثل اخواتهم سواء في
شمال غرب سوريا او حتى في تركيا انا اقول
لك اليوم انا في الحقيقه فعلا انعدمت
الانسانيه من هذا العالم الغربي الذي كان
يقول بانه يدعي الانسانيه بانه يدعي حرصه
على الشعب السوري وانه يريد ان يساعد
الشعب
السوريات وامام هذه هذا المصاب الجلل يعني
لا تنفع اي من شعارات الانسانيه يحملها من
يحملها يعني في النهايه من يدفع الثمن هم
الاطفال الابرياء الذين راينا صورهم تدمي
القلوب في الايام الماضيه
هؤلاء هم هم البوصله يعني لاحظتي انت كانت
السرعه كانت الدقيقه هي لها تمام في انقاذ
الارواح عندما تكون هناك فرق غير مدربه
وغير ولا تستطيع ان يعني تعمل في هذه
الاجواء ربما يكون الكارثه موجوده في
الشمال الغرب سوريا يعني يعطيهم الف عافيه
وكثر الله خيرهم على كل هذه الجمعه التي
في سوريا وحتى في المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها الدوله يعطيهم الف عافيه صح كلامك
وشكرا لالك لهذا الكلام في ناس منامه
والناس عم تشكك فيها عمال الهلال الاحمر
العربي السوري افراد الجيش العربي السوري
من وزاره الصحه دكاتره واطباء وغيرها
وقتنا شكرا جزيلا على هذا التوضيح كان
معنا الكاتب والمحلل السياسي غسان يوسف من
دمشق
عبرت احدى عشره شاحنه من المساعدات
السعوديه الى الداخل السوري عبر منفذ باب
الحمام الحمام الحدودي وتبلغ حموله
الشاحنات من المساعدات 104 اطنان تشمل
مساعدات غاثيه ودوائيه وغذائيه وسيتم
توزيعها في المناطق الاكثر تضررا في شمال
غرب سوريا من هنا من الحدود السوريه
التركيه حيث دخلت عبر منفذ باب الحمام
مساعدات سعوديه اغاثيه محمله بمئه واربعه
اطنان من كافه انواع هذه المساعدات التي
ستدخل الى داخل سوريا تحديدا الى المناطق
الاكثر ضررا وهنا نتحدث عن مناطق شمال
غربي سوريا عبر هذه المساعدات التي دخلت
نحن نتواجد الان في الجانب السوري من هذا
المنفذ حيث دخلت فعليا هذه الشاحنات التي
سيتم توزيعها على اقرب منطقه
تعرضت لي اكثر ضرر من هذا
الزلزال وجراء هذا الزلزال وهنا نشاهد
اداره جمرك باب الحمام والعلم السوري في
هذا في هذه السياره في هذا المكان المحاذي
او في بدايه هذا المكان في الاراضي
السوريه في الحقيقه عبر المتعهد سوريا
الذي سيبدا بتوزيع هذه المساعدات مباشره
بعد ان دخلت الاحد عشر شاحنه محمله بكافه
انواع هذه المساعدات قال بان هذه
المساعدات ستوزع في مناطق شمال غربي سوريا
وتحديدا على اكثر من ما يقارب 22 منطقه
تعرضت لضرر كبير جدا جراءه هذا الزلزال
وهذه المساعدات اختير هذا المنفذ لها لان
هذا المنفذ هو الاقرب لهذه
المناطق المتضرره جراء هذا الزلزال كما
قال بان هذه المساعدات هي الاولى من نوعها
الد التي تدخل الى سوريا بعد ان ضربها
الزلزال قبل سته ايام عبد المحسن الحربي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث منفذ باب الحمام
السوري
ما تزال القصه الرضيعه التي ولدت تحت
الانقاض ببلده جنديرس شمال سوريا ولقبت
بعنقاء الزلزال ما تزال تحظى باهتمام وسط
اخبار الموت التي خلفها زلزال المدمر
كاميرا العربيه رافقت منقذه الذي زارها في
المستشفى استعدادا لنقلها الى بيته خلال
الايام القادمه جديد القصه في متابعه
مستمره للزميل عبد القادر خربوش
[موسيقى]
يحدوه امل في ان يجد عنقاء الزلزال في صحه
جيده حيث تقضي ايام حياتها الاولى بهذا
المشفى بعفرين رفقه ابنه جرى اول لقاء
لهما بها بعيدا عن الدمار واهوال الزلزال
[موسيقى]
سعاده تشاركها مع زوجته التي شاءت الاقدار
ان تضع هي الاخرى مولودتها تزامنا مع
الولاده العجيبه لهذه الرضيعه فقرر ان
يمنحاها اسما ويتكفل برعايتها الى جانب
ابنتهما طلب مني حموده ابني قال لي سميها
عفراء على اسم خالتي
فسمعتها عفره على اسم امها من ساعتها انه
ابوها راح وامها واخواتها ضلت هي ذكرى
البنت عندي من اهلها صارت وحده من اولادي
يعني ما راح ان شاء الله ما راح اميزها هي
من اولادي يعني وراح تكون اغلى من اولادي
ان شاء الله زاد
لا يكاد خليل يستوعبوا كيف تشبثت عفراء
بالحياه واصطدمار اودى بحياه كل افراد
عائلتها والاف عجزت اجسادهم عن مقاومه هول
زلزال لم يبقي ولم يذر برضينا الله يرحمه
عائلته كانوا ولد عمي يعني واقرب الناس
الي وكان اكثر من اخ لالي هو وكان المقرب
لالي اكثر شيء هو فراحت عيلته كلياتها
زوجته واطفاله واخته فما ظل احدهم غير
البنت ذكرى من عنده فبدي يربيها انا وراح
تظل هاي ذكرى للابد
قصته مع عفراء تعيده الى المكان الذي قطع
فيه حبلها السريه من والدتها ونجح في
اخراجها من تحت هذه الانقاض لتصبح عنوان
امل يحفظ في ذاكره الملايين عن الكارثه
لا يتصور العقل ولا يعني شي فوق الخيال
النص الساعه اربعه نشتغل جبنا اليات بلشنا
للساعه 2:00 لقينا الطفله هاي تقريبا
وبقدر ما لاقت قصه ولاده الرضيعه تفاعلا
واسعا شكلت بالنسبه لمنقذها خليل منعرجا
حاسما في حياته وسيكون يوم اخراجها من
المشفى ونقلها الى بيته بدايه جديده لفصول
قصه جميله اختصرت مشهد الموت والحياه عبد
القادر خربوش العربيه
[موسيقى]
سنواصل معكم تغطيهنا لازال مشاهدينا لكن
الان نتوقف امام بعض الاخبار الخاصه
بملفات اخرى
فقد اكد حاكم مدينه خارج الاوكرانيه
سقوطها ثلاثه صواريخ روسيه على منشات
للبنيه التحتيه في المدينه مضيفا في بيان
له نشر على تطبيق تيليجرام ان الجيش
الروسي استخدم صواريخ من طراز اس 300 في
الهجوم فيما لم تحدد السلطات حتى الان عدد
ضحايا وحجم الدمار الا ان مصادر اوكرانيه
اكدت تضرر محطه لتوليد الطاقه الكهربائيه
مما تسبب في اصابه ثمانيه اشخاص في حصيله
اوليه
اعتبرت المتحدثه الرسميه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ان عمليه تحويل مولدوفا
الى اوكرانيا اخرى ليست مستمره فحسب
ولكنها تكتسب زخما
ان عمليه تحويل مولدوفا وهي دوله ذات
سياده لها تقاليدها واهدافها الى اوكرانيا
اخرى ليست مستمره فحسب ولكنها تكتسب زخما
في الصحافه المولدوفيه تتم مناقشه مساله
جدول الحفاظ على الاثار السوفيتيه بشكل
علني سياسه تمجيد المتواطئين مع النازيين
مستمره
اعلن البانتوجون عن رصدي خلل في اجهزه
الرادار وعدم العثور على اي جسم طائر فوق
ولايه مونتانا امس السبت وذلك بعد ارسال
طائره مقاتله للتحقق كما اكدت قياده
الدفاع الجوي لامريكا الشماليه
انها ارسل الطائرات مقاتله للتحقق للتحقق
مشيره الى ان الطائرات لم ترصد اي شيء
يرتبط باشارات الرادار وانا ستواصل مراقبه
الوضع وياتي اعلان البنتاجون بعد ساعه من
اعلان كندا اسقاط مقاتله امريكيه لجسم
بخصائص مجهوله فوق اقليم يوكان الكندي
تظاهر الاف الاسرائيليين في احتجاجات
شهدتها عده مدن ضد مشروع قانونا يهدف
لاصلاح نظام القضاء اقترحته حكومه بني
يمينه نياهو وبحسب صحيفه هارت فقد بلغ عدد
المتظاهرين في موجه الاحتجاجات الجديده
التي تشهدها اسرائيل بلغت 50 الف شخص بسبب
ما وصفوه بممارساتنا ياهو المهدده
للديمقراطيه
نقلت وسائل اعلام تونسيه خبر اعتقال
القيادي السابق في حركه النهضه عبد الحميد
الجلاصي ضمن حمله اعتقالات نفدت الشرطه
تونسيه يوم السبت كما نشرت وسائل اعلاميه
اخرى خبر اعتقال الناشط السياسي خيام
التركي فيما لم يصدر الى حد الساعه اي
تصريح رسمي من وزاره الداخليه التونسيه
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا معكم في هذه التغطيه
المستمره منذ تقريبا سبعه ايام نحن ندخل
الان اليوم السابع لهذا الزلزال المدمر
وتبعات هذا الزلزال مشاهد قاسيه وصعبه جدا
لكننا مستمرون في هذه التغطيه معكم والان
نذهب الى الرياض مع الزميل احمد الى
اللقاء